now then did you know the Green Party
had its best-ever election results in
London last week coming third in the
mayoral race it was a good week to for
the Scottish Green separate party who
saw their end must rise from to ms piece
26 troubling while I'm joined now by the
party's leader Natalie Bennett sandvik
smile on your face and oh why wouldn't
there be particularly with that London
performance but I mean do you think did
you are more of a metropolitan party
than anything else oh absolutely not if
you look around the country you we've
won our first councillors on on a wide
range of places right down from down in
Weymouth down in the southwest up to
Cannock where we've got a really great
candidate who got more votes almost than
the Tories and labour put together to
win our first seat on cannock council in
hennis ferd we're spread right around
the country we did very well in
Sheffield this is a case for the Green
Party really the green surge last year
we're really consolidating and growing
right around the country but I mean are
you just benefiting really from Labour's
weaknesses I mean there's some policy
overlaps there and you know labour
didn't do too well with the best will in
the world and parties like yours then
benefit well actually you'll find the
majority of seats that we talk were
actually off the Tories you'll find
around the country and if you take
places like q Sully hole we were there
already the official opposition on the
council we grew there in stroud we grew
there there's a wide range of places all
around the country we were growing
developing under but as you say London
is a huge course of celebration sean
barie really was rewarded for an
excellent campaign a real positive
campaign putting forward lots of good
ideas ideas about transport and housing
and I do also in your UK word roundup
have to add the Northern Ireland greens
yeah who got who out double their
representation now have two seats on the
northern ireland assembly but is there
now I mean we've talked for some months
and indeed years about the fragmentation
about people moving away from from the
big parties did we see it in these in
these elections last week that there is
now almost a crying out for a real
progressive alliance not let not the ad
hoc nature of you know we're against the
government and will vote wherever we
like for all you other leaders and
parties to think I suppose you know more
pragmatically and systematically about
getting your heads together well I think
we're the the loudest cry is coming very
loudly and clearly and this was hurting
whispers yes terday at the make vote
mater rally is for a change in the
electoral system and into
first-past-the-post which really is
clearly thoroughly out of date if you
take a seat up on the we're all where we
got in a six candidate race we got
forty-three percent of the vote and our
candidate wasn't elected forty-three
percent of electors you didn't see their
wishes fulfilled first-past-the-post is
designed for a two-party system we no
longer have a two-party system if you
look at the last figure i shore from the
BBC where they were extrapolating
towards the national vote share and
imagining a general election you it was
thirty-nine percent of people we're not
voting labor or Torry electoral reform
absolutely has to be on the agenda now
that's both in the local government
elections and indeed course in
Westminster but I mean on the question
of you know where things stand now I
mean I was looking at the London result
the women's equality party did did very
well as well there in London and what
one thinks again lots of lots of
overlaps between your parties aren't you
cutting each other's throats well I
think you were always as the Green Party
prepared to work with people with agree
with us on any issues working together
cooperatively that's something that's
always happened and always will happen
we're interested in putting our policy
ideas into action but I think we really
must not get away from the fact that you
cross the road here from Westminster the
last significant change in the commons
was women getting the boat that was
nineteen eighteen it really is time that
we are we up to the centenary of that
that would be a great point at which to
change intellectual sister cuz you know
Westminster really looks a bit moments
tail doesn't it compared to when we've
looked at those election results as they
came in right across the nations and
regions so many great powerful female
leaders of parties and a First Minister
as well I mean what Westminster really
is a bit of a shake okay well exactly
and if you look again in London you look
with two of the candidates Rashid nicks
and Samir Jarrah oh she did great for us
in the constituencies in Lambeth and
Hackney you know those are places where
the electoral system is just not
allowing great people to come through
because it's so stuck in that to party
framework we really need to need to see
changes need to see development across
there and you know one of the people
getting more women there and we do any
quilters or something like I well I I
was at the demonstration yesterday we
had the 50-50 Parliament campaign which
a great campaign and you know we have
twenty-nine percent women there but if
it's not the only issue of course you
know we really have huge
under-representation of people from the
black Asian minority ethnic communities
and a representation of disabled people
under representation of people from all
sorts of different backgrounds um
there's really only one group I think we
could definitely see a lot less of and
that might be you know people who went
to Eton really now what's happening two
years to say female leaders of parties
and your term up / very soon as as
leader of the greens when do you leave
and who takes over do we know or do you
all well you all kind of intent and harm
or something excuse me flowers alone
it's a low blow but III tell us your
successor select I think that's called a
bit of very out of date story write-ups
from it well what were the way it works
in the Green Party is is every two years
the post of leader is up for re-election
at the moment I'm still focused on these
elections in fact we're still working
here from the results from Bristol
Council and all that council election
which has been countless afternoon would
you see this is your high water mark
this is your legs no at the moment I'm
thinking about what happens next I'll be
thinking about that at the right time
once we're finished this set of
elections which we haven't finished yet
all right I was an upward sir Natalie
Bennett thank you very much indeed the
Green Party leader there